in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Andrews
with us hey Andrew how are you man - an
amazing welcome where do you live I live
in this community or Cup near Albany and
you're here for our counselor training
been going through becoming one of our
coaches yes sir Chris Hoban did an
amazing job les all those guys and gals
very cool good and while you're here you
woven a debt-free scream huh I said did
I love it so how much have you paid off
Andrew one hundred ninety seven thousand
two hundred dollars excellent how long
did that take just over eight years
eight years is that your house and
everything that is house and everything
man you have a paid-for house I do
indeed how weird are you the weirdest
love it making what kind of household
income during this time it's a bit of a
long haul but I started out solo making
around $12 an hour met the most
wonderful woman in the world I got to
marry her and we started together around
75 peak a little over 100 and now we're
back down to around 85 now that she's
staying at home with her son okay cool
cool so she's not with you today no four
days in a hotel with a ten-month-old is
kind of a certain sort of torture gotcha
okay got you okay cool fine but she's
watching on the app and she's gonna
scream with me at home I love it that's
good very cool
so what started this journey eight years
ago tell me how you worked your way out
of that well going back a little bit
when I was a young man I had kind of a
cocky philosophy about life I used to
say that your 20s are for earn and your
30s are for learning and I have that
backwards I had your 20s or for learning
your 30s or for earning meaning you
spend your young years learn and having
fun things experiences traveling 30s you
get serious for me it was more like my
twenties were for spending my 30s were
for mending I was in the Navy
and I probably did every ounce of the
five miles of stupid outside of every
base that you talk about and but you
know then I moved out to LA with some
buddies of mine Oh first went to college
college debt moved out to LA you know
live that lifestyle racked up more debt
you know you know going out to parties
with celebrities that sounds like
learning to me and you know got out of
that and around 30 years old it was when
I had a little slap in the face moment
and I knew something had to change but I
didn't have any information yet
and I started reading a little bit
didn't hadn't found you yet but right
around 32 I was making progress but I
think God looked down and said need to
go a little faster and he gave me a
little kick in the pants called stage 3
colon cancer at age 32 Wow
and I said you know life is too short to
be anything other than free that kind of
experience this just changes your
priorities after that stuff didn't seem
so important people were important
family was important and I wasn't gonna
be cancer and I'd beat cancer bad I
wasn't gonna beat cancer in the Bank of
America push me around there you go so
it was funny just around that time you
know they say when the students ready
the teacher appears in a good friend I'm
out of a job I had his name's Richard he
introduced me to you and at first I'm
like no no you're supposed to pay the
highest interest first I was I just
listened to the CDs they gave me the FPU
CDs and I dove in for three days I
didn't come up until I just that was it
and the motivation and the information
it was like rocket fuel and I just took
off and my progress looked like the tail
end of a compound interest chart after
that and it's just been and then I met
my wife and you know she sipped the
kool-aid a little bit first but like
that last couple was saying you talk
about powdered but I think she I have a
little married but syndrome she didn't
want to hear it from me but she read the
Total Money Makeover we did FPU at home
and no one was that that wasn't but we
did FPU in 2012 but she read the Total
Money Makeover 2009 okay and that's
about the time you really kick this into
gear then yeah well that's about the
time the eight years begins
well the eight years begin when I was 32
okay and I'm 40 now
okay then with her we started together
in 2009 so now your fees paid off is
amazing it's amazing that's cool now I
heard a rumor you guys were doing this
stuff at work
yes that's correct yeah we did the
financial wellness program last year it
was core this year it's smart dollar and
it's been incredible I just really
wanted to bring this transformation to
the people I worked with and you know it
was a great team put it all together and
we've had almost 500 people go through
it well average financial turnaround in
90 days is somewhere around nine
and dollars Wow we're hoping to expand
it next year it's just been crazy so you
know Brian Deb all those folks over
there phenomenal team smart dollar
product as we talk about rocket fuel
it's all firemen yeah oh yeah very cool
well congratulations thank you so much
threatened to love 500 people now
because you did this and Counting way to
go man absolute absolute and here to
becoming a coach as well all right
that's right it's like this whole week
bucket list item bucket list item bucket
list item shook your hand last night
bucket list item Wow and that didn't
change anything that's completely
underwhelmed
way to go brother I'm very proud of you
and they say one more thing if you don't
mind last night I was so nervous and
Chris Hogan in our after-after-party
whatever you want to call it he had this
he was saying something about coaching
that just applied to this he said don't
ever try to tamp down the butterflies in
your stomach
just get them flying in formation ah
that's good medium Zen peace about an
hour ago but I got it well it's good to
have you brother so I'm proud of you man
all right a hundred and ninety seven
thousand dollars paid off in eight years
and beating colon cancer in the process
you can't beat this this is awesome
Andrew and your wife's first name is her
name is Courtney my son is Arthur okay
all together screaming over the over the
app and everything else count it down
let's hear a debt free scream accordion
Arthur this is for you
everybody with me three two one we're
dead
very well done
oh man that's fabulous that is good
stuff
you